PROFESSOR: I think it's about
five after the hour so we
ought to get started.
Before we forge bravely ahead,
I'd like to make sure that
everybody has a copy of
the things that we've
been handing out.
There is a copy of the
handwritten notes on the
derivation of the
17 plane groups.
Need a copy of that?
There you go.
And then there is, in addition,
a set of diagrams
from the international tables
that give very nice pictures
of all of the plane
groups in the
arrangement of symmetry elements.
That's the only other thing
that was handed
out up to this point.
For your continued edification
and amusement, I have another
problem set.
And let me say something
about this problem set.
The first problem gives you some
angles between crystal
faces and asks you to deduce
a possible set of lattice
translations which are
consistent with those angles.
And in the days before
diffraction, that was what
crystallography was all about.
It really was mapping the
geometry of crystals.
And the interesting thing is,
you could measure these angles
very precisely with a device
called a reflecting
goniometer, Provided you had
a crystal with nice,
shiny faces on it.
You had a two circle instrument,
and you could
adjust the crystal so that a
light beam, a very finely
collimated beam of light, was
focused into an eyepiece.
And you could measure angles to
within not one minute, but
one second of arc.
And from this you could deduce
if you could assign Miller
Indices to the faces.
You could deduce not the
absolute magnitudes of
translations, but you could
deduce the ratio of them.
And along came x-ray diffraction
and shook
everything up.
Turns out, sometimes you were
right and other times you were
wrong, because you had
determined a self consistent
set of indices, but not the
ones that were correct.
So this is to give you a little
look at the early days
of crystallography, and to see
if using the way Miller
Indices are defined you can
calculate the ratio of axes.
Not terribly demanding,
but worth doing.
And we had talked earlier about
these combinations of
symmetry elements as
constituting the
elements of a group.
And in the second problem
I ask you to take a not
terrifically simple, but a
fairly complex point group,
4mm, and show that, indeed,
the operations that are
present satisfy the
group postulates.
And that is worth doing once so
that you convince yourself
these really are groups.
And then the third problem is
easy to state and it is
diabolically tricky.
So I'll let you have a go at it,
but don't beat your brains
against your desktop for an
entire evening over it.
Try it.
If you don't see the solution
to it, all will be revealed
later on in class.
But it's based on the fact that
the plane groups, which
we've now derived, 17 of them,
these can be viewed as the
base level of a three
dimensional space group.
And for each of them, you
could take another
translation, t3, that was
perpendicular to the plane of
the group, and just imagine all
of those rotation axes and
all of those mirror planes
not being two dimensional
operations, but three
dimensional operations.
The only one where you could
pick the translation,
generally, would be the oblique
lattice, p1, no
symmetry at all.
And there you could pick the
translation in any orientation
you wished.
But for each one of the 17 two
dimensional plane groups,
there is a corresponding three
dimensional space group.
So we got 17 three dimensional
symmetries for free without
really doing any additional
work.
However, there's one
thing that one
should not gloss over.
We found that a rotation point
in a two dimensional plane
allowed only a very limited
number of lattices.
But we were not thinking of
things in terms of three
dimensions.
So what I'm inviting you to do
in the third problem is to
consider, now, that construction
that we did where
we showed that rotation angles
were restricted to values of
cosine of alpha equals
1 minus p over 2.
Now generalize that to a three
dimensional situation, where
the translation does not have
to be perpendicular to the
rotation axis, but can
be inclined to it.
Are there additional rotation
axes allowed?
Are their fewer?
Something we ought to examine.
But there's a little bit of
ingenuity that you have to use
in that proof.
But I invite you to have
a go at it on your own.
So with that tantalizing
introduction that will want to
send you running home and start
it as soon as we finish
our class this afternoon, let
me hand out, without any
further blather, problem
set number five.
Pass that in the back corner.
Last time, without saying much
about them, I handed out this
extract from the international
tables that summarized the 17
two dimensional plane groups
and their properties.
And I'd like to spend a few
minutes going over the
considerable information that's
contained on these pages.
Each one is treated in the same
way, and let me start
with one that's almost trivially
simple, and that's
the two-fold axis in
the oblique net.
Across the top of the page you
find, in boldface, the symbol
for the plane group.
And then, just counting in order
of increasing symmetry,
the number of that particular
plane group in the set.
And then a symbol that really
has its full meaning only in
three dimensions, but it gives
the symbol for the lattice,
again, 2 and then a 1 and a 1,
which says that if this were a
three dimensional space group,
there would be a two-fold axis
in one direction and no symmetry
at all in the other
two directions.
And then, next comes the symbol
for the point group of
the crystal.
And we derived this particular
group by dropping point group
2 into a lattice.
And then the coordinate system
that is necessary to describe
the features of this plane
group, if you take the edges
of the unit cell as the basis
of a coordinate system.
So this is something called
a crystal system.
So for each of the plane
groups, you have this
information spread across
the top of the page.
Then underneath that is a
diagram that, by means of open
circles, shows the way in which
that particular symmetry
moves a motif where atoms, in
the case of a crystal, moves
atoms around.
And for p2 we have the pair of
motifs of the same chirality
related by a two-fold axis.
And that, then, is hung at
every lattice point of an
oblique net.
And then, immediately to the
right, is the arrangement of
symmetry elements
in the group.
Then, the way in which that
particular plane group can
move atoms around to generate
a structure is
summarized for you.
And the first thing they have to
state is where you're going
to choose the origin.
There is no unique
lattice point.
It's convenient to take the
origin at a location of high
symmetry, and in this case the
smart thing to do is to take
the origin at one of
the two-fold axes.
That's a non trivial question,
because there are some groups
that have different kinds
of rotation axes.
P4 has a four-fold
and the two-fold.
Taking the origin of the
coordinate system at a
location of high symmetry, then,
gives you the scope of
picking either a two-fold
or a four-fold axes.
Yes,sir?
AUDIENCE: On the left hand
figure, what's with the--
those aren't mirror planes
[INAUDIBLE] are they?
PROFESSOR: On the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Here they
have this.
That's just to split things up
into quadrants, so you have a
feel for how the atoms hung at
the lattice points split up
into different quadrants.
That is a very good
point, though.
Mirror planes are shown
as bold lines.
Sometimes the outlines of the
cell look pretty bold
themselves.
So if you turn the page to pm,
if you have the notes with
you, can see the lines that are
reference lines for the
cells are lighter in their
weight than the symbols for
the mirror planes.
But it's a very subtle
difference.
And when you Xerox it a couple
of times it becomes almost
indistinguishable
AUDIENCE: Can you just say, one
more time, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That means that this
is the location of 0,0.
And it is always assumed, but
nowhere stated specifically,
that the origin is in the
upper left hand corner.
And what is also assumed, but
never stated, is that the
x-coordinate in the a-axis goes
down and the y-coordinate
in the b-axis goes from upper
left to the right.
That is nowhere stated anywhere
in the international
tables, but that is the
direction that is assumed for
the reference axes.
So we'll take our origin
of the two-fold axis.
That's a sensible thing to do.
And then there are two ways
you can look at how the
particular plane group
generates a pattern.
You can do it with little
circles or little commas, or
something like that.
In other words, do
it graphically.
But a way to communicate the
atomic arrangement in a
structure, which is going to be
the most free of ambiguity
and rigorous, is to do
it analytically.
And that's what the tables
do for you next.
They give an analytic
description of the way in
which the symmetry elements
will move an atom around.
For this particular plane group,
things are very simple.
This is the direction of x, this
is the direction of y.
And if we plop one atom in
here, it will be at a
location x and y.
So that's what happens when
you drop one atom in it.
That atom gets hung at every
lattice point, and it gets
rotated by the two-fold axis.
So you're going to get two of
them per lattice point.
Somewhat arbitrary which
pair you take.
The coordinates of this
atom are x and y.
The coordinates of this atom
inside of the box is 1, minus
x and 1, minus y.
That would do it, but it makes
sense, esthetically, and to
see that the atoms are related
by symmetry, if, instead, you
specify as the two atoms per
cell the two that are hanging
at the lattice point.
And in that case, the
coordinates of the first, if
they are x and y, would be
minus x and minus y.
If you have a pair of numbers,
0.283 and 0.456, then minus
0.233 and minus 0.456 leaves
no doubt that these are
positions that are related
by symmetry.
If you have coordinates, like
0.2, 0.3 and then 0.8, 0.7,
without doing some arithmetic
in your head, it's not clear
that those are going to be atoms
related by symmetry.
So the coordinates that will be
stated for you, then, will
be the coordinate of the pair of
atoms at the lattice point,
and some of the coordinates
would be negative.
This is something called
the general position.
And that transformation of
coordinates is different for
every one of the plane groups.
That's what makes
them different.
They're different in the way
they move around an atom in a
general location and
fill space with it.
So that's the general position,
and it is unique for
each plane group.
And there are several ways in
which this information is
conveyed to you.
Move this over a little bit;
x, y and minus x, y.
The first thing that's a
characteristic of the position
is the number per cell.
So you get the number 2, or this
is sometimes referred to
as the rank of the position.
Drop in 1 and you get a second
one out related by symmetry.
The next is, and I'll go to
the last next, this is the
site symmetry.
And by definition, this is
always 1, no symmetry at all,
for a general position.
So why make a big deal about all
of these characteristics
of the general position?
The reason is that there are
locations that are termed
special positions.
And let me clean up this right
hand part of my diagram.
And say that, for plane group
p2 you will always get two
atoms per cell if you
place an atom in an
unspecialized location.
What would be a specialized
location?
Suppose we would drop the atom
down right smack on top of
that two-fold axis?
Then that two-fold axis is just
going to twirl the atom
around on its axis and it's
not going to map it into a
second location.
So following the general
position is always provided to
you a set of special
positions.
And what's special about them?
They are on a symmetry
element.
You can look at the
characteristics of a special
position in two ways, either
geometrically or you can do it
analytically, as I'll show
you in just a moment.
Imagine that the atom is to
sit here, x and y migrate
progressively towards
the location 0,0.
And then the other atom related
to it by two-fold
symmetry will move towards it
until finally the two of them
will merge into just
one single motif.
So when that happens you get not
two per cell, you get only
one per cell.
And the reason for that is
the site symmetry is 2.
It's on a two-fold axis.
But there are other two-fold
axes as well.
What if the element migrated
to the position 0, 1/2?
If that were the case, if the
representative atom moves to
here, this one up here will
migrate down and the two will
merge into one atom that
sits at just 0, 1/2.
So there'll be another type of
special position, one per
cell, also, on a
two-fold axis.
This one was at 0,0, and
this one is at 0, 1/2.
You remember, we made a point of
saying that there are four
different kinds of two-fold axes
within this plane group.
Different in how they're
positioned relative to a
pattern, different in that they
are not mapped into one
another by some other symmetry
element which is present.
So each of these four locations
is a location of
another general position
of rank 2, sitting
on a two-fold axis.
x and y migrate down to 1/2, 0,
and this one and this one
will come together.
So there's another one, giving
you one per cell, sits on a
two-fold axis, and this would
be at the location 1/2, 0.
And finally there's another one
in the center of the cell,
and if you let the atom migrate
to that location,
again, the atoms will coalesce
pair wise into a single one.
So there'll be another one, one
per cell, and also on a
two-fold axis, and this would
sit at the location 1/2, 1/2.
And those, then, are the
characteristics of this
particular simple plane group.
There's another symbol that's
added, and this is something
called the Wyckoff symbol.
Wyckoff was a crystal chemist
who attempted valiantly, back
in the early days of the
century, when there were a
couple of dozen structures
determined per year because it
was such a grand, new adventure,
and few people knew
how to do it.
But Wyckoff tried to summarize,
between one pair of
hard covers, all of the
crystal structure
determinations that had been
performed in a single year.
And he went at this courageously
for perhaps a
dozen years, and then results
began to accumulate so rapidly
he just said, the heck with it,
clapped covers on it, and
that was the end of the
series of books.
So they don't get very far,
but it was a real useful
contribution at the time.
This is just a shorthand way of
referring to the position.
And he starts with a for the
most specialized, runs the way
up through the alphabet until
you've assigned a letter to
each of the positions.
This is a nicety.
All these special positions, for
example, sit on a two-fold
axis, and you don't really
have to specify the
coordinates, because they have
to be either 0 or 1/2.
So this gives us a way of saying
you have an osmium atom
in position 1a and you have an
oxygen atom in position 1c.
And it's a nice shorthand way of
avoiding mentioning things
which could be calculated once
and for all and not stated
explicitly.
So this, my friends, is the
language in which you will see
structural datas cited, when
people have determined, using
diffraction methods, the
locations of all of the atoms
within the units, some of
a particular material.
If the coordinate is variable,
with today's techniques and
high speed computation, you can
get x as a fraction of a
cell to usually at least
plus or minus 1
in the fourth place.
So it's data that can be
determined extremely precisely.
Yes sir?
AUDIENCE: I didn't quite get
the exact definition of the
general position.
It's a set of points
related by--
PROFESSOR: The general position,
it's a set of
equivalent positions that
are related by symmetry.
Yeah.
And the general position,
yeah--
Each of these is called a set
of equivalent positions,
equivalent in the sense of being
related to one another
by symmetry.
And the entire set is sometimes
referred to as an,
singular, equipoint.
Sort of a condensed jargon for a
set of equivalent positions.
So when one speaks about an
equipoint of rank 2, in this
case, or rank 1.
Let me just, even for this
trivial two dimensional
symmetry, give you an example of
some information that falls
out of this immediately.
First of all, you can
use these special
positions only once.
If you put an atom in position
1c at 1/2, 0, it's used up.
You can't put another atom in
there in a given structure.
Secondly, if you think more
globally, not in terms of
atoms, which, to a good
approximation,
are spherically symmetric.
But think in terms of a
molecule, if you're a polymer
scientist or an organic
chemist.
and not place an individual
atom, but
place an entire molecule.
If there's one molecule per
cell in this particular
symmetry, that molecule has
to sit on a two-fold axis.
And that means the configuration
of that molecule
is going to be limited to
having to conform to a
two-fold rotational symmetric.
So just from the density in the
lattice constitute, if you
find there's one molecule per
cell, you know that molecule
has to have two-fold rotational
symmetry.
So you can say something about
the structure of the molecule.
So there are lots of ways in
which the symmetry information
has something to say about
the arrangement of
atoms in the structure.
Any further questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How did they decide,
between b, c, and d, which was
the most special form?
PROFESSOR: That is a
very good question.
And the way it's decided is by
you getting there first before
anybody else did it.
So everybody follows, now, the
conventions that are given in
the international tables.
That's sort of the dictionary
of all these terms.
But you're absolutely right.
What is more special about
this one than this one?
Well, they're all locations
of the same symmetry.
You can turn one into another by
changing the origin of the
cell, where you're going to
define a lattice point.
So they are thoroughly
arbitrary.
What is generally done is to
take 0, 0 for your particular
choice of origin
as position a.
And then what should come
next, 0, 1/2 or 1/2, 0?
The truly observant among you
will notice I snuck a quick
peek at the international tables
before I wrote one of
these down.
I can never remember
which is which.
And it is arbitrary.
Usually you end up with the one
that has both coordinates
non-zero, but that is code
that's embodied in the
international tables.
But that's a good question.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: How did you decide to
make the motifs [INAUDIBLE]
special decisions?
PROFESSOR: Oh, I just changed
the value of x and y.
Those are numbers that can be,
for the representative atom,
each of them can be
between 0 and 1.
So what I just said was, what
will happen if we let x and y
take on not general values,
but very special values?
And the special values are going
to be things like 0 and
1/2, if I have picked my origin
at a two-fold axis.
It's another reason for picking
your origin at a
location of high symmetry.
AUDIENCE: But how about the
other non-origins of these
special decisions [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: There are two
ways you can do it.
One of them we just did.
We just looked at the geometry
and we said, if this
representative atom, this is the
one we define as being at
location x, y.
If x and y both approach 0,
this atom and the one over
here are going to migrate
towards the origin lattice
point and eventually
just coalesce.
If I let x and y and migrate,
x go to 0 and y go to 1/2,
then this one and this
one will come
together and coalesce.
So that's why I did that,
because I knew that the number
I would generate would be
smaller than the number that I
would get for a set of
coordinates for an atom that
was off the symmetry element.
I said there's another
way of doing it.
For something this simple it is
not really that profound,
but it is a way of checking
whether you've counted the
same position twice.
I said you can imagine these
special positions arising when
x and y assume special values.
So let's let, for example, x
be 1/2 and y be 0 and plug
those coordinates
into my equation
for the general positions.
So I'll put in 1/2 for x, 0 for
y, and then I'll put in
minus 1/2 for x and
minus 0 for y.
But what goes on at minus 1/2
has to be the same as what
goes on at plus 1/2, if the
structure is based on a
lattice and periodic.
So what I'm really getting is
1/2, 0, 1/2, 0 twice, which is
the same as saying, if x is
1/2 and y equals 0, I'm
putting two atoms together right
on top of one another.
So you can do it analytically.
And for the more complicated
symmetries, where there might
be for 20 or 48 atoms, that's
a good way to see if you've
looked at the same
position twice.
So we're going to do a couple
more before we move on, and
this one is almost
trivially simple.
Any other questions before
we go forward?
Let's take one that is slightly
more complex.
And I'll go to one of the
rectangular groups.
And let me look at, let's take
plane group p2mm, which has a
fair amount of symmetry to it.
So this is the group that we
got by putting 2mm into a
lattice that had to be
rectangular, then.
And across the top of the page,
this is number six,
you'll see that it
is rectangular.
It has to have a lattice in a
rectangular shape because of
the symmetry.
Next comes the short
hand symbol.
And I always feel a little bit
apologetic when I have to
point out the existence of this,
and the reason is that
people who work with symmetry
are no more or less lazy than
any other human being.
And some of the symbols become
really ungainly when we go to
three dimensional symmetry.
And something like a 2 sub 1
over a 2 over m 2 sub 1 over d
is a mouthful.
And actually what's done is to
just specify the minimum
amount of information, which
defines the symmetry.
00:30:01.290 -.780
So we'll see some more cases
where we can immediately state
that without further thought.
OK.
There is something that we
might consider doing.
I'd like to put it
off, though.
Here we start with
a mirror plane.
Can we replace the mirror plane
with a glide plane?
The answer is yes, we can.
But it's not at all clear if I
take a fourfold axis and put a
glide plane through it, what
this plane has to be.
So I'd like to leave this one
for now and come back to that.
OK.
In the notes, I've tried to do
all of these derivations
thoroughly and logically.
So if this is a bit fast or me
waving my hands, saying a
glide plane is here, and this,
that, and the other thing,
when you can't really see what
I'm pointing at, I think if
you refer to the notes
that'll be clear.
But yes, you had a question?
AUDIENCE: So you said that this
glide plane [INAUDIBLE]
one-half T perpendicular.
What did you write
underneath that?
I guess that maybe is where
your T and one-half T
perpendicular is where
the glide plane is.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I was just demonstrating that,
in fact, for this mirror plane
with the diagonal translation,
the glide plane would come in
at one-half of the perpendicular
part of the
translation.
And the part of the
translation that--
we were combining this fourfold
access with this
translation.
So the perpendicular part of the
translation is half of the
body diagonal.
And if a glide plane comes in
one-half of the perpendicular
part of the translation, that
put it parallel to the mirror
plane and at one-quarter of the
way of the translation.
So this little scrawl here
says it one-half of T
perpendicular and one-half of
one-half of the body diagonal.
So it's one-quarter.
All this equals one-quarter
of T1 plus T2.
OK.
Now something unexpected
happens.
If we would move along,
I skipped over 3m.
We know what P3 looks like.
And that is a hexagonal net,
an equilateral net.
And we have a threefold axis
that we've added to the
lattice point.
And then we found additional
threefold axes in the center
of these triangles.
And, once again, the pattern
that has this symmetry is just
a triangle of objects hung
at every lattice point.
And now we want to add
a mirror plane to
that threefold axis.
So we have a primitive
equilateral net plus the
two-dimensional plane
point group 3m.
The question is, which
way should we
orient the mirror plane?
Well, a mirror plane says, I
want to be along the edge of
either a centered rectangular
net or a
primitive rectangular net.
There's nothing about this
lattice that looks
rectangular.
Yeah, there is.
I see a couple of people
doing this, and they
have the right idea.
Here's a lattice point.
If we go more than one unit cell
in this diagram, here's a
lattice point.
Here's a lattice point.
Go down to here and
go over to here.
And lo and behold, here is a
centered rectangular net,
hiding incognito in
a hexagonal net.
Well, that helps.
I can put in the mirror plane.
But let me point out-- this is
getting very messy, so I'll
redraw it on a smaller scale.
This will be worth doing so that
it's perfectly obvious.
I'm going to draw a number
of equilateral nets.
The reason I'm drawing more than
one cell, I would like to
point out that here is one
centered rectangular net.
And it has its edge
perpendicular to the
translations in the
hexagonal net.
But there is also a rectangular
net that
goes down like this.
That's a centered rectangular
net that has its edge along
one of edges of the unit cell.
So I have two possibilities.
One is to draw the rectangular
net like this.
The other one is to draw the
rectangular net like this.
And having confused you
thoroughly, let me simply draw
this larger cell again.
And say that I could, if I
wanted to, put the mirror
planes in in these directions,
along the edges of the cell.
OK.
And in this case, if you're
convinced that there's a
centered rectangular
net sitting there.
Let me clean this up.
And here's one mirror plane.
60 degrees away is another
mirror plane.
And there'll be another mirror
plane at this lattice point
doing this.
So now I've got 3m at every one
of these threefold axes.
And I got all those simply by
repeating these mirror planes
by translation.
But in one case, the mirror
planes are perpendicular to
the cell edge.
This being T1, let's say,
and this being T2.
In this case, the mirror
planes are along the
edges of the cell.
This being T1, and
this being T2.
So, holy mackerel!
One point group.
Two different space groups,
which differ in the way in
which the symmetry is oriented
relative to the lattice.
00:41:00.470 -e symmetry m.
And that would be a pair of
objects that has x equal to 0.
y is anything, so that's
this mirror plane here.
And in that case we'd have a
pair of atoms, left to right,
reflected by the mirror plane
that goes through the origin.
And then last one, thank
goodness, is one at a location
1/2, y and 1/2, minus y.
And this would be the mirror
plane exactly at 1/2.
y can be anything.
x is 1/2.
So that would be a pair that
sits somewhere on either side
of the mirror plane running
through the
center of the cell.
That's also a site
of symmetry m.
Now we assign the Wyckoff symbol
by working our way up
the alphabet.
So this is a, this is b, this is
c, this is d, this is e, f,
this is g, this is h,
and finally we end
up at position i.
For all of these, we get
two atoms per cell.
These have rank 2.
For each of these we get
just a single atom.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain the
two atom per cell thing?
How do you [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Which one would you
like me to do, that last one?
1/2, y?
AUDIENCE:[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So if x is 1/2 and
y is anything, that's this
locus here.
And that is a mirror plane.
And if we let this atom move
from its location, x,y, down
to this location, the one in the
lower part of the cell is
going to move up and these two
will coalesce to a blob that
sits there.
AUDIENCE: That would be 2m?
PROFESSOR: So this would
be site symmetry m.
And instead of getting four per
cell I would get two per
cell; this one and the one
that's reflected across.
Now the other way of doing it is
to not think about it all.
Say here is x,y, minus x, y, x,
minus y, minus x, minus y.
And then let's make one of the
coordinates specialized.
Let's let x be exactly 1/2.
So I'll get 1/2, y, minus 1/2,
y, and then I'll get 1/2,
minus y and minus
1/2, minus y.
Looks like four atoms, except if
I have one at plus 1/2, the
one in the neighbor unit
cell is at minus 1/2.
So actually I've had the atoms
coalesce pairwise, because
these coordinates are actually
identical to saying 1/2, y
plus 1/2, y, 1/2, minus y, and
minus 1/2 is the same as plus
1/2, minus y.
So you can do it that way.
Just put in a special value for
x or y, turn the crank on
the general position, and you'll
find you're going to
get the same thing twice.
And if we look at position
a, which is 0,0.
put in 0 for x, 0 for y, then
put 0,0 for all these other
four positid there'll have to be a glide
halfway between these
mirror planes, and a glide
that's halfway between these
mirror planes.
In this case, the mirror
planes are this way.
Again, a translation that's
inclined to the mirror plane.
We have to have a glide
that is midway between
these mirror planes.
In this case, they're a little
easier to identify.
They sort of make a triangular
box that surrounds the
threefold axis.
So now we see another difference
in the plane groups
and the reason why they're
so very distinct.
And that is the rearrangement of
the glides relative to the
threefold axes are quite
different in these two cases.
So these are two quite
different symmetries.
Notice that when we start
identifying special locations
in these two plane groups, here
there is a location only
of symmetry 3mm for a point
group, 3m for a point group.
Here there are two different
locations, one that's symmetry
3m, the other one is
just symmetry 3.
So this is location of point
group 3 and a location of
point group 3m.
So the sort of special positions
that exist in these
two plane groups will be
very, very different.
One more addition, and then I
think we can leave with a
light heart because
we should be done.
What about a primitive
hexagonal net
combined with 6mm?
And if you think I'm going
to try to draw
that, you're crazy.
But I can say quite simply and
hopefully convince you that
this looks like P31M plus P3M1
right on top of one another,
because we've got mirror
planes that
are 30 degrees apart.
So, as a schematic direction and
an invitation to do this
at home in your spare time, is
to take what P6 looks like.
And that's sixfold axes
at the lattice points.
Threefolds here.
Twofolds here.
And then, directly on top of
this, place the mirrors and
glides in this orientation, and
the mirrors and glides in
this orientation.
So we will have mirror planes
coming out like that, and
glide planes in between all the
parallel mirror planes.
As I say, I'm heroic
but not foolish.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you just explain
that derivation again?
Your P3 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
The object of this additional
bit of confusion is to put in
the symbol the point group,
which is 3m, and then tell you
how the mirror plane in a
point group is oriented
relative to the edges
of the cell.
And we could call them anything
we wanted to.
We could call them P3M
perpendicular, subscript
perpendicular.
Or P3M subscript parallel to
indicate mirror plane parallel
to the cell edge.
And mirror plane perpendicular
Or we could call them some
obscenity, which would be very
descriptive, as well.
But this is just a way of
keeping track of what's
parallel to the cell
edge and what's
perpendicular to the cell edge.
So, this middle symbol is what's
oriented perpendicular
to the cell edge.
And in this case, this is the
mirror plane and that is
perpendicular.
All the mirror planes are
perpendicular to the
edges of the cell.
And then parallel to the
cell edge, there's
no symmetry at all.
So that's 1.
1 stands for no symmetry.
In this case, the mirror plane
is along the cell edge, so
there's an M in the
third position.
And perpendicular to the
cell edge, there's
no symmetry at all--
no symmetry plane at all.
So it's purely arbitrary, but
we need some mechanism for
distinguishing which one
we're talking about.
That pretty much works
as well as anything.
And it's a minor perturbation
of what we've done for the
additional plane
group symbols.
All right.
It's time for our midafternoon
break.
It's a nice place to quit,
because you're probably
feeling good.
We've done this, and we can
move on to something new.
Actually, there's
one more trick.
And unless you were really
clever, you wouldn't have
thought of it.
But there's another small family
of plane groups that we
can get through one
particular device.
I shouldn't have told you that,
because you'll be less
inclined to come back now.
But we're almost through.
And I think it'll be very clear
what these additional
Would this be a location for
a special position, this
two-fold axis?
It was before.
Is it now?
Key point is independent
sites of symmetry.
There's a mirror plane here.
What goes on here has to
be exactly the same as
what goes on here.
So this is not an independent
special position.
In the same way, there's
a mirror plane.
And if I let the atom migrate
down to the mirror plane I
will have the mirror plane
at a location 1/4, y.
And these will be on
a mirror plane.
1/4, y would be a first, 3/4,
minus y would be the second
one that I get, and they would
coalesce pairwise.
Is this is another mirror plane
that could be regarded
as an independent position?
This mirror plane, again, is not
independent, because it's
related to the one we just
considered by the two-fold
rotation about the center
of the cell.
So there's only one kind of
mirror plane in the structure.
But, going back to the two-fold
axes, there is a
two-fold axis here.
There's another one that
is halfway along y.
So there's another two-fold axis
that is independent at 0,
1/2, 1/2, 1/2.
And this is the entire set.
So there are three special
positions of rank 2,
two atoms per cell.
We make the most specialized one
be named a, work our way
up to c, and the general
position, then, is
referred to as d.
Again, so what I did was to say
that this mirror plane is
related to this one by symmetry,
and if there's
something on this mirror plane
as a special position, I'm
automatically going to get it
on the lower mirror plane.
This two-fold axis is the
same as this one.
So whatever is going on as a
result of specializing the
location on this two-fold axis
is going to be provided for me
automatically at x equals
1/2 by the action
of this mirror plane.
There's nothing that throws this
two-fold axis into this
one, though, so they're
both independent.
Now, one of the symmetry
elements that I steadfastly
ignored was the glide plane.
What happens if I place an atom
right on the glide plane?
A glide plane, if you use a
motif that has some handedness
to it, we repeat the atom
by translating half of a
translation, not yet putting
it down, first
reflecting it across.
This is an enantiomorph.
Doing it again gives me an atom
that's related to the
first by a translation.
What happens if I let the atom
migrate onto the glide plane?
Let this atom move
down to here.
Now it sits here.
This one, repeated from
it by glide, will
migrate up to here.
Nothing happens.
It's just that the amount that
the atom is displaced from the
locus of the glide plane is
different in the two cases.
But there is no coalescence of
the atoms, because of this
translation component
to the glide plane.
So a conclusion, then, is that
glide is never a candidate
location for a special
position.
This is a good example of a case
where I can check what
I've done, and to see
if I counted the
same position twice.
I said that both of
these locations
are not special position.
The mirror planes are
related by symmetry.
Suppose I were not clever enough
to notice that, and I
said, OK, there's going to be
a special position, 1/4, x,
3/4, minus y.
That's what happened if I
use this mirror plane
as a special position.
What would I get if I took
3/4, y and 1/4, minus y?
Looks like a different
specialized position.
But let me put this number into
my expression that is the
formula for the general
position.
If x is 1/4 and y is y, then
this position here would be
minus 1/4 and plus y, 1/2,
minus x would be
1/4, and y is y.
Over here, I got the same
thing back again.
And 1/2, plus x would be 3/4,
and minus y is minus y, minus
1/2 and 3/4, plus 3/4
are the same thing.
So what I've gotten is the
position 1/4, y, and 3/4,
minus y twice.
So what this is telling me,
analytically, if I just plug
in the coordinates of what seem
to be a distinct, special
position is, I get the same atom
on top of itself twice.
And it looks exactly
like choosing the
first mirror plane.
So that's a good way of
checking, particularly in a
very high symmetry where there
are all sorts of sites of
possible point groups that could
cause coalescence, to
just crank out the coordinates
and see if, in fact, you have
exactly the same pair with
the same coordinates that
correspond exactly to the
x and y of some previous
location that you identified.
I think, hopefully, you have
a feeling for how it works.
If you look at some of the
higher symmetries, the number
of atoms that constitute the
full equipoint set of
equivalent positions.
For p6mm there are 12 locations
in the general
position, and because the
coordinate system is oblique,
x and y get permuted
into linear
combinations of one another.
So that's really, extremely
complicated.
If you look at some of the
square symmetries, the number
of the special positions
is very, very high.
There are two positions
in p4mm, there are two
positions of rank 1.
There is a position of rank
2 that sits on 2mm.
Three different mirror planes,
and the general position with
rank 8 requires working your way
all the way through g in
the alphabet.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I had a question about
the p2gg [INAUDIBLE]
whether they're at the entrance
of the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: For p2gg, the only
site of point symmetry is a
two-fold axis.
So the only thing that you
could use for a special
position in p2gg is
a two-fold axis.
And there are two different
two-fold axes.
They relate in a curious way
because of a glide plane.
And this is a case where the
site of a special position is
not related by rotation or
reflection, but by a glide.
P2gg looks like this.
Two-fold axes in the old
familiar places, 0, 1/2.
The glide planes are here,
here, here, and here.
So which two-fold axes
are equivalent?
The glide would take this
two-fold axis, reflect it
down, and slide it
over to here.
So whatever goes on here goes
on at this two-fold axis.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I guess my question was, can
you put the glide planes at
any edges of this sites?
[INAUDIBLE], or--
PROFESSOR: You could.
You could, but you would lose,
then, the apparent similarity
in coordinates in that, if you
put the glide plane at the
two-fold axis, if this is x,
y, this one over here is at
minus x, minus y.
And then if you repeat it by
glide, that would slide over
to here and then be reflected
down here.
So there'd be one pair up here
and one pair down here of
opposite handedness, so you
would not see the similarity.
No, that's right.
If you took the origin at the
glide plane, you would not see
the simple relation between the
numbers that you do when
there is that a rotation
axis of a mirror plane.
But you can take the origin
anywhere you want.
And the advantage of doing it at
a symmetry element is then
the numbers that describe where
the atoms sit are simple
permutations of sign, or adding
1/2 to the number of
the preceding atom that was just
mapped to a new location.
I think you're more than
ready for a break.
Let's resume in 10 minutes, and
we'll move on to something
completely different.